Traductor: Laura Ferrari
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Yo les quiero contar que
siempre odié los números.
Además, tuve la desgracia
de hacer un secundario contable,
así que, básicamente,
yo odiaba ir a la escuela.
Me acuerdo de anotar en el banco
la cuenta regresiva de los minutos
que faltaban para que sonara
el timbre del recreo.
Así que cuando terminé el secundario,
corrí a toda velocidad hacia las ciencias
sociales y me formé como psicóloga.
Yo quería hacer algo creativo, divertido,
que nos gustara a todos.
Así que me especialicé como sexóloga.
Empecé a atender y empecé a recibir
consultas en las redes sociales.
Y me encontré con algunas preguntas.
Por ejemplo:
"¿Con qué frecuencia debe tener
relaciones la pareja?"
"¿Por qué llego al orgasmo
más rápido si me masturbo
que si tengo relaciones con alguien?"
Y otra, que no es una pregunta, pero
la recibo muy a menudo, es:
"¡Soy precoz, ayuda!"
(Risas)
Y la última consulta, que también
se repite casi a diario, es:
"¿Cuánto me tiene que medir el pene?"
Como si hubiese un control de calidad
antes de que el pene salga al mercado.
(Risas)
Estas preguntas a mí me resonaban.
Esto del tiempo, la frecuencia,
la velocidad, la masa.
(Risas)
Y, primero, me empecé a sentir de vuelta
como si estuviera en el secundario.
Después, me di cuenta de que
las preguntas que nos hacemos
sobre la sexualidad, las hacemos
con la idea de que existe una fórmula.
Una receta, general, invariable,
que si seguimos al pie de la letra
ciertos pasos,
vamos a tener un resultado correcto.
Lo que hacemos es medir la sexualidad.
Y lo pensamos como si fuese una ecuación.
Primero, pensamos que la situación sexual
requiere de cierto tiempo.
En promedio, estamos hablando
de unos 20 minutos.
En penetración.
Que incluye un pene, siempre erecto,
de unos 20 centímetros.
Nadie sabe adónde lo van a meter.
Pero más o menos pensamos
que tiene que medir 20 centímetros.
Y una vagina, que se espera
que esté lubricada.
De nuevo, nadie sabe
cómo se produce la lubricación.
Pero tiene que estar lubricada.
Y hablamos de un pene y una vagina
porque entendemos que la norma es hetero.
Esto, vamos a esperar que nos dé
como resultado un orgasmo.
(Aplausos)
Y si es en simultáneo: amor.
Todos flasheamos amor.
(Risas)
Esta ecuación la vamos a repetir
tres veces por semana.
Me encantaría decirles que
por el resto de sus vidas,
pero entendemos que
la gente grande no coge.
(Risas)
Así que le damos hasta los 60, 65.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa
si yo no logro alcanzar
alguna de estas variables?
O, ¿qué pasa si yo sigo
la ecuación al pie de la letra
y, sin embargo, el resultado
no es el esperable?
Lo que va a pensar esa persona,
lo primero que se va a decir
a sí misma, es:
"Tengo un problema.
No soy normal. Estoy fallado".
Lo que yo les quiero decir hoy
es que no sos vos el que falla.
Lo que falla es esta ecuación.
Así que, ¿qué les parece
si la rediseñamos?
(Aplausos)
Al igual que yo contaba
los minutos que faltaban
para que suene el timbre del recreo,
en la cama hacemos algo muy parecido.
Es sabido que el hombre tiene un tema
con esto de no eyacular rápido.
Entonces, por ejemplo, cuando viene
a la consulta un hombre
que está preocupado por esta problemática
y vos le decís:
"Contame, ¿cómo fue el encuentro?
El último encuentro sexual que tuviste".
El tipo te responde:
"En el primero, dos o tres minutos.
En la segunda vuelta duré un poco más".
El hombre no está en la situación sexual.
No está teniendo sexo con vos.
El hombre está luchando en su cabeza
con un "No tengo que acabar".
Y en función de eso empieza
a desarrollar un montón de técnicas.
Esto de pensar en algo feo,
respirar, quedarse quieto.
(Risas)
Como si quisiera ganar tiempo.
Como para pasar de nivel
antes del "Game over".
(Risas)
En cambio, a la mujer le pasa algo
absurdamente opuesto.
La mujer se exige llegar rápido
al orgasmo.
Por eso no hablamos
de "precocidad femenina".
Entonces, tenés en la consulta
a la mujer que viene y te dice:
"Yo me masturbo pero no llego".
"Pero, ¿qué te pasa en esa situación?"
"Me estoy tocando, me frustro
y sé que no voy a llegar".
"Pero, ¿cómo sabés? ¿Qué te pasa?"
"Empiezo a pensar que
estoy tardando mucho..."
"¿Cuánto?"
"No tengo idea, pero 5 o 10 minutos".
Medimos el sexo.
Y lo medimos con el tiempo.
Ahora, dejame que te diga
que si en la situación sexual,
en vez de estar concentrado
y conectado con tus sensaciones eróticas,
estás midiendo el tiempo en tu cabeza,
y eso te aumentará la ansiedad.
Y la ansiedad corta la respuesta sexual.
Y va a pasar todo lo que
no querés que pase.
En el hombre, seguramente
eyacules antes de lo esperado
o pierdas la erección.
Y en la mujer, se inhibe la excitación
y te alejás del orgasmo.
Así que, ¿qué les parece si en vez
de preocuparnos por el tiempo,
nos ocupamos por estar relajados?
Que es el mejor estado para irte
a la cama con alguien.
Vamos a cambiar la primera variable
de la ecuación por "estado relajado".
Para poder pasar a la variable central
de la sexualidad: la penetración.
Porque, si hay algo que asociamos al sexo,
es la penetración. ¿O no?
Por algo decimos "ponerla".
(Risas)
Al hombre, la penetración
le funciona bastante bien.
El pene, en la zona del glande,
es donde más terminales nerviosas tiene.
Entonces, lo que hace el hombre,
muy inteligentemente:
en la penetración se estimula
y se fricciona la cabeza del pene
contra las paredes vaginales o anales,
o donde la quiera meter.
(Risas)
Estoy haciendo una paja en vivo
para todos Uds.
(Risas)
Filmame esto.
(Aplausos)
Ahora bien,
también hay hombres que disfrutan,
por ejemplo, de ser penetrados.
O disfrutan de que se les estimule
el resto del cuerpo.
Les juro que el hombre
tiene resto del cuerpo.
(Risas)
No son solo un pene bonito,
hay mucho más.
Y en la mujer, les cuento también,
la penetración y la vagina,
está un poquito sobrevalorada.
(Risas)
La mujer tiene la zona donde recibe
más placer, la zona más sensible,
en la parte de la vulva,
que es la parte externa.
Entonces, en la penetración
no es tan fácil de estimular.
Por eso la mujer responde mejor
a la estimulación manual, oral,
o se fricciona contra algo:
la panza, la pierna,
froti-froti contra un almohadón,
froti-froti contra un control remoto
que dejó en la cama,
el celular, el vibrador...
Porque lo importante es que tenga
la estimulación adecuada.
Así que, ¿qué les parece si
en vez de "penetración"
hablamos de "estimulación adecuada"?
Para eso, ya nos olvidamos
del pene y de la vagina,
y podemos pensar
en las zonas erógenas de cada uno.
Que tampoco hay un mapa
que funcione para todos.
Cada uno tendrá que ir explorando.
Pero tenemos una nueva ecuación, entonces.
Vamos tranquilos, relajados,
salimos de la penetración.
Vamos hacia todo el cuerpo,
a buscar la estimulación adecuada.
Para llegar al orgasmo.
Una vez una paciente me dijo
que ella tenía un contador de orgasmos.
Yo pensaba que con el del monotributo
ya estabas, pero no.
Contador de orgasmos.
Entonces, ella iba teniendo relaciones
con su pareja e iba contando
los orgasmos que llevaba en la semana.
Y, en función de eso, era la percepción
que tenía de la pareja.
Porque eso es lo que hacemos.
Contamos los orgasmos
y contabilizamos y medimos el sexo.
Como si lo quisiéramos controlar.
Lo paradójico de esto es que el orgasmo
implica una pérdida de control.
El orgasmo es un momento de mucho egoísmo
donde tenés que poder entregarte y soltar.
Y, a veces, esa entrega nos moviliza.
A veces, esa entrega nos expone
a un estado de vulnerabilidad.
Entonces, yo me pregunto:
¿dónde está la variable que nos enseñe
a sentirnos cómodos y seguros
en nuestro cuerpo,
cómodos y seguros ante un otro?
Ni hablar de si es una noche
de sexo casual.
¿Dónde está la receta o la ecuación
que nos enseñe, que nos diga, por ejemplo,
que si yo viví una situación de abuso,
o que si yo fui víctima,
en reiteradas oportunidades, de violencia
física, es probable que eso me impacte
en mi experiencia sexual adulta?
Porque un cuerpo que sintió dolor
es un cuerpo que va a necesitar sanar
para poder sentir placer.
La sexualidad se construye
y se reconstruye en cada cosa que hacemos,
sentimos y pensamos.
No es algo que va en paralelo
a nuestra propia historia.
La realidad es que somos responsables
de nuestra sexualidad.
Y la ponemos en juego
en cada decisión que tomamos.
En el estilo de vida que tenemos,
en los hábitos de salud,
en las experiencias positivas
o negativas con un otro.
No hay una manera
de generalizar la respuesta.
No hay manera de que pensemos
en una ecuación,
o en un modelo de sexualidad común.
Así que, lo lamento,
y entiendo que romper esta ecuación
y salirnos de la norma de la sexualidad
nos puede dar miedo.
Pero lo que nos da, es libertad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)